welcome to the 13th ever episode of the
iced coffee hour
at this point we have gained 2 359.
gained earned i think we're yeah that
means we're averaging about 30
a day that's pretty good that's really
good yeah and we were able to um
secure some guests really excited about
these guests today i'm really excited
uh so why don't we welcome them to the
show welcome graham and jack come on in
it's just great thank you so much i
think you're a better host than we are
just need to take over how did this
start you're making some really good
videos right now and you did like it's
too good i think like the quality i
think is is
is too too much too high of quality i
really
really appreciate that um our history
dates back
to um 10 years ago in or about 10 years
ago in 2011 we started making youtube
content
um i had just graduated college i grew
up here in los angeles
and um i played lacrosse which was a
very foreign sport to play
in los angeles i had this idea coming
out of high school and going into
college that there should be
a network for the sport like there
should be the nfl network for lacrosse
and when i graduated college it was
unlikely that that was going to end up
on television but i still wanted to do
the idea and so just took to youtube to
start making content about
lacrosse and at the same time during
that exact same
you know two-month span of us starting
this network uh myself and a friend
colin was making content about his
lacrosse team in colorado
there was only two people making
lacrosse content on the internet and it
was
us in la and colin in colorado and so it
was like small community
yeah it was a small community so we
connected very quickly i uploaded and i
think 30 minutes later i had an email
yeah so that's so cool and we were
really viewing it as like a network so
we wanted to acquire content
and um he was making like a docu-series
it was a
very good filmmaking very good
storytelling and we wanted to
acquire his series so that's how we met
um
convinced him to move out to la for a
three-month internship
yeah and then he stayed for nine years
now
we've been making content together ever
since we had we had a really great ride
with
that company it's called lacrosse
network we built it from 2011 to 2014
and we ended up selling the company
to a new york based media group called
whistle sports
at the time they had just brought on
dude perfect as their primary partner to
go into youtube
and we then became you know we brought
on our company
uh and our goal was to build that brand
but then
also join the team and help build out
athlete and
sports content across social platforms i
gotta know how long does it take you to
make a video
the amount of work that i bet you put in
it it's mind-blowing to me
because we're actually you know in this
ever evolving process of trying to
pin down um and
balance between letting your creativity
flow but then also being efficient and
making sure
that you're getting enough videos out to
support yourself as
a company and and uh you know for us we
oscillate between some of our videos
take 10 days uh because they have
interviews
they have a ton of different pieces of
b-roll they have
writing sessions rewriting sessions uh
colin you know totally leads on that
process
and he from day one since the
day i met him he's just like super
intensive on storytelling
and if the story doesn't make sense it
doesn't go out uh and that means like
every frame builds on top of each other
and if it doesn't we're gonna lose
people's attention we're gonna
not you know create something that's
conversational at all
um and so now we're starting to work
into spaces where
when we started talking about ourself
like we made a video that you commented
on
called how much youtube pays us which is
kind of like a i see anything money
related i comment on that i loved it
very on brand for you um but that video
took
less time because the storytelling of it
was
like personal and we were able to tell
our own story and doing that it was it
was a lot easier to
flip that video around so we're trying
to balance now and understand what are
the videos that are the big swings like
you know the video we made with mr beast
obviously that's a big swing i love that
video
that's gonna cross a million views uh
you know probably in the next
week or ten days and that was a big
swing that's worthy of spending a ton of
time on
now we also need the frequency of
building a community and having a
conversation with our audience
so we have to tear off our videos and
say this is a tier one video that is a
big swing
and here's a tier two video that's you
know probably in the
we're aiming for a hundred thousand
people to watch it how do you know
everybody
like how do you get mr beast for an
interview like that
yeah it seems like you know a lot of
people in space it's like you are you're
the one who's interconnected
i think uh we've always i've i've
personally always prided myself on
networking
um i think somehow it just happens
coffee shops yeah but also
we've used videos as networking tools um
we made a video about will smith uh two
years ago
and within an hour we got an email from
his management company and then we were
able to connect with them the real
audience for that video even though it
hit
maybe 300 000 views was actually the
five people in the will smith management
office
that's who it was directed at so they
got it immediately
even like you said like you'll see
anything about money so there was a
purpose you knew going into it that
that was your intention that was just a
better version of cold outreach in an
email okay but what about mr beast
because you had him in the video how did
that happen
beast came from uh i so
we also met yes theory in that way we
made a video about them and that's how
we met them we became
very close with them yes theory ended up
doing a video with mr beast
um we made a video about mr beast he saw
it
didn't reach out to us and then uh i had
a i had one of the s theory guys on my
podcast talking about the experience of
working with mr beast
and right after he dm'd us and he was
just like hey guys i really like your
videos
um can i call you and i gave him my
number and since then he's just been
that's fun a super close connection uh a
guy who's like an amazing mentor
i think he's a great person to be
who he is on our platform because of who
he is uh
and he just has a very vested interest
and
creators growing and he's taken an
interest in us
and uh that's awesome again super cool
we're now at a point finally
where we're able to like actually do
this full-time as
youtube creators which was not the case
over the past three years we've been
operating as like a creative agency
um we've been
like doing uh doing projects for other
people that
don't have anything to do with our
youtube channel there's even a point
where we made videos for a real estate
company
about a building yeah which was super
interesting and
um yeah now we're doing youtube
full-time youtube
like from an adsense perspective it's
pretty small
like i didn't see it yeah let's see um
how many people do you have working with
you so we have a full-time editor
uh named jesse shout out to jesse i know
his wife you know what is this
editing software jesse uses yeah of
course yeah yeah we all use premiere i
mean we're all editors you all use
premiere yeah we all use premiere
i'm trying to choose what i'm gonna like
translate here's our revenue over the
past
four weeks and then you can go to
lifetime
how how it did james look at that
well that always how
so do you what do you mind if i say it
or no please say okay yeah i don't care
about this
one let's round it up 1.4 million views
in 28 days
2800 that doesn't make any sense no it
doesn't make any sense
can we see the but it's our cpm what is
the cpm
our cbm is probably somewhere around
four dollars maybe five bucks
why is it so no let's let's see the
reason is but that's what i was saying
is that you talk about money and money
has a trades that are really high
but our iced coffee hour is not like
here yeah
here's the iced coffee hour literally a
hundred and thirty thousand views
a thousand dollars yeah right and what
what
is that revenue revenue australia hey
guys from australia watching yeah thank
you so much for watching
you guys are trading at over double rcpm
almost triple
yeah but but even then that doesn't make
sense i think even double
why we've made more money in adsense
this month even though it's
not much than we've ever made before
more money this month than ever and
part of that i think has to do with the
fact that three out of our last five
videos
have to do specifically with money right
yeah so i think that's that's one thing
but you know we're lucky to have
a very significant brand partnership
with samsung uh
and that really changes the way that we
operate
yeah we also have long-term partnerships
with uh
storyblocks and a couple other brands
and so that
allows us to have recurring revenue that
then bases like how we're operating as a
business and let's us experiment
we've just moved into the direct to
consumer space um with our paid
educational course
what is that so it's not sponsored yeah
it's an i'm gonna plug it every time i
get but uh
it's it's a uh online storytelling
course it's about our process of coming
up with ideas and and filmmaking and
um how we basically uh brainstorm and
craft an idea before we turn on a camera
so it's a very extensive process an hour
and a half of content we're adding to it
throughout this year
that is selling at 100 price point it's
been out for a week and we've been able
to convert 265 people
uh to purchase that course uh in the
past week and so
for us that's a really interesting model
i think that's where we fit in more
naturally we feel like we are kind of
educators yeah we feel like we're
building a relationship with our
audience where they are willing to
pay to uh learn from us and to be a part
of our community into workshop ideas and
uh we see ourselves as being able to
turn into kind of a modern day
film school and a modern day um you know
media academy
yeah uh and i think that's where when i
look at our revenue
like i definitely think we'll have uh
brand partners like a samsung that's
just like
we're with them they're like our our uh
ambassador brand or we're ambassadors
for them
um but i don't see the content that
we're making being that
advertise like ad supported or
advertising i think we'll probably move
into direct to consumer content
smash the like button smash uh the like
button yes for the youtube algorithm
yes for the youtube algorithm algorithm
algorithm yeah cool
thanks guys until next time